fermé pour fermer aux tons faire
profiter des gens nécessiteux qui ont
absolument besoin
[Musique]
on est père j'ai des gens quittaient la
rue et notamment des femmes sortante de
maternité et on les hébergés dans des
hôtels dans des chambres d'hôtel et puis
après on a fait la connaissance de
taulier qui compte qu'on vous côtoyez
j'allais dire et quand vous voyez qu'ils
étaient en souffrance économique et donc
du coup de fil en aiguille on a
rencontré cet hôtelier là et qu'on lui
avait proposé est ce qu'il y avait la
possibilité d'ouvrir cette structure
[Musique]
cette solution elle nous permet de de
garder les salariés de travailler comme
on a l'habitude de faire
voilà bon c'est moins que le tourisme
c'est clair mais au moins ça va nous
permettre de
de passer cette période de crise voilà
et attendant des jours meilleurs on va
dire
[Musique]